hey guys my name is Jess McDonald it is
the 25th of June today and the show
you're watching right now is called
gangs but news and the spirit of
shameless self-promotion which is a
spirit I just invented for this sentence
you can also go watch my other show that
just after this if you want for now
though let's do news first up today
upcoming shooter Rainbow six siege is
going to feature male and female
hostages this is relevant since
controversy was sparked after its e3
showing which featured an unsettling
damsel in distress situations Ubisoft
technical artist Olivier Couture said
we're also going to have male hostages
that's part of the plan he also said the
choice to make the hostage female in the
e3 demo was to make players want to
protect her and try to keep her alive
since if she dies one team will lose the
game Couture explained we're trying to
define next-gen with the hostage we call
that a living hostage so she'll react to
explosions and things like that it's
pretty cool choke off because of dirt in
the air and covers herself when there's
shooting those lots of things we want
the player to be able to move her into
different positions for there to be
fluid control it's a balance between
player comfort and reality I'm undecided
as to whether that sounds cool or still
thinking realistically that a victim
would at least pick up a damn knife let
me know what you think next up minecraft
is doing better on consoles than it is
on pc and mac which i personally found
pretty astounding developer mojang
announced today that minecraft console
additions together have just the past
minecraft for pc and mac and it across
all platforms they've sold just under 54
million copies said console iterations
presently include xbox 360 and ps3
although the game is coming to xbox one
ps4 and Vita before too long just in
case you forgot there's also a minecraft
movie in the works at Warner Brothers so
that's the thing we get to hope isn't
crap Marcus of ditched its family
sharing plan in the great policy
reversal of 2013 but it seems that
apparently gone does not mean forgotten
during a recent gamertag radio podcast
Phil Spencer said we looked at the
digital features that we talked about
last year and as a gamer there were
lot of those features that I think
really resonated and were smart features
for people who really have a lot of
games and maybe play on a couple of
consoles or have a bunch of people in
the house all want to share with friends
he pointed out that the on-disk drm
makes family sharing somewhat difficult
to implement but that they haven't moved
out the possibility of reviving the
plans Spencer also said that Microsoft
are currently committed to enhancing the
xbox one's digital features by including
a pre-loading functionality much like
the one sony has on ps3 and ps4 let me
know in the comments of things like
family sharing and pre-loading
functionality actually mattered to you
when it comes to buying a new gen box
that is it from me today I'm
unimaginative when riding out roads and
I will see you tomorrow